nos dicen que como parte de un
experimento sobre velocidad de trenes
cuatro distintos conductores midieron la
distancia que recorrieron en un cierto
intervalo de tiempo durante un viaje
reciente aquí tenemos los cuatro trenes
en esta columna el tiempo que les tomo y
aquí la distancia recorrida sin embargo
todos ellos usaron distintos intervalos
de tiempo este cuate usó media hora
este otro cuatros o dos horas y están
teniendo problemas al comparar sus datos
de acuerdo a los datos proporcionados se
movían los cuatro trenes a la misma
velocidad durante el experimento tenemos
que calcular entonces la velocidad de
estos cuatro trenes basada en la
distancia que recorrieron en este lapso
de tiempo para esto recordemos aunque
quizás ya lo sabes que la distancia es
igual a la tasa de cambio por tiempo o
si dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación
entre tiempo tenemos que dividimos del
lado izquierdo entre tiempo del lado
derecho entre tiempo estos tiempos se
cancelan y nos queda entonces que
la tasa de cambio es igual a la
distancia sobre el tiempo tasa de cambio
en este caso es velocidad y hace sentido
tenemos millas por hora o metros por
segundo o kilómetros por hora la tasa de
cambio que en este caso es velocidad es
distancia dividida entre tiempo usando
esto dividimos la distancia recorrida
entre el tiempo empleado para cada tren
y así calcular su velocidad hagamos eso
entonces calculemos la velocidad voy a
poner aquí otra columna para incluir la
velocidad velocidad ahí la tenemos
entonces para este amigo recorrido 27.5
millas en punto 5 de horas calculemos su
velocidad es distancia que es 27.5
millas dividido entre punto cinco horas
hagamos esta división esto es lo mismo
que 27.5 por dos deja de ponerlo de la
siguiente manera 27.5 por dos y 27.5 por
dos es igual a 55
5 y esta velocidad está en millas por
hora en este caso la velocidad es de 55
millas por hora ahora para este amigo es
bastante directo recorrido 55 millas en
una hora velocidades distancia entre
tiempo por lo cual la velocidad de 55
millas por hora 55 millas por hora lo
podemos poner la fórmula 55 es la
distancia 1 es el tiempo 55 entre 1 es
55 millas por hora
el siguiente conductor recorrió 80 y 2.5
millas en 1.5 horas cuánto nos da eso 80
y 2.5 millas en 1.5 horas calculemos eso
voy a tener que hacer la división larga
para calcular esto dividamos entonces
entre 1.5
82.5 multiplicando por 10 ambos números
o recorriendo el punto decimal a la
derecha es lo mismo recorro el punto
decimal aquí y también lo recorro acá
tenemos que dividir 825 entre 15
empecemos 82 entre 15 15 por 6 el 90 82
entre 15 es 55 por 5 25 llevamos 25 por
15 y 27 75 estemos 75 82 75 nos da 7
bajamos el 5 que tenemos acá 75 entre 15
como ya vimos esto es igual a 55 por 15
75 75 75 es cero entonces la velocidad
de este amigo es también 55 millas por
hora y finalmente si recorre 110 millas
en dos horas 110 dividido entre dos es
55 millas por hora así es que al final
de cuentas todos los conductores
viajaron a la misma velocidad d
25 millas por hora